تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث اكد
المتحدث باسم القوات البحريه الاوكرانيه
للجزيره تضرر سفينه انزال روسيه في خليج
نوفروسيس كاروسي لكنه نفى مشاركه القوات
البحريه في العمليه وكانت وكاله رويترز قد
نقلت عن مصدر امني اوكراني قوله ان جهاز
الامن الاوكراني بالاشتراك مع القوات
البحريه الاوكرانيه نفذ عمليه في خليج
نيوروسيسكاروسي استهدفت سفينه انزال روسيه
بزورق مسير يحمل نحو نصف طن من المتفجرات
ونشرت وسائل الاعلام روسيه مشاهد قالت
فانها لسفينه عسكريه روسيه تضررت نتيجه
هجوم اوكراني على البحر الاسود فجر اليوم
المقابله وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في بيان
لها ان القوات الاوكرانيه حاولت مهاجمه
ميناء نوفروسيسك بالبحر الاسود باستخدام
زورقين مسيرين وان الزورقين المصيرين تم
تدميرهما بنيران اسلحه السفن الروسيه التي
تعمل على حراسه الميناء من الجهته هكذا
حاكم اقليم كاسنودار ان محاوله القوات
الاوكرانيه مهاجمه المنشات في ميناء
نوفروسيسكا لم تسفر عن اصابات واضرار
ماديه كما اعلنت وكاله سيستينا فالانشطه
في ميناء بعد تعرضه لهجوم اوكراني بدورها
افدت شركه خط انابيب بحر قزوين ان البنيه
التحتيه للخط لم تتضرر الانفجارات قربان